right welcome to the dpnr meeting for
the 18th of august everybody
and i have just one apology from
councillor joan ward i'll move from the
chair that that be accepted could i have
a second name
uh mr mia all those in favor please say
aye it's carried
are there any conflicts of interest that
need to be recorded today
appear to be none confirmation of
minutes for the 25th of february 2020
gosh that's a long time ago
are there any additions or corrections
to the minutes that any members have
noticed
i can't remember um anyone who was at
that meeting who'd like to move the
minutes
councillor redmond and secondary
councillor mailings
any discussion i'll put that we
move them that the minutes be accepted
all those in favor please say aye
ethically that carried any matters
arising from those minutes
there appear to be none now we are due
to have a reputation but what i've
she's just i've just got an email from
her she's just at the chambers
you like to just turn your microphone on
the stairs sorry
thank you madam chair um right our
deputation's running a little late so
what we will do
is we'll move on to item 6.1
in your agenda which is the proposed um
property maintenance bylaw who's
speaking to that today
i can do a quick introduction if you
like better chair just a a very quick
summary
um it's been well canvased you'll
remember back in 2018 and particularly
with regard to the change in law when
finns took over this matter previously
to be part of the local government act
and councils could act in some way
against the
amenity issue of long grass and then it
went defends and they have a very
focused lens
of fire risk in late 2018 there was a
notice of motion from then councillor
gordon
and councillor williams for the council
to look at a bylaw for
property maintenance as that was scoped
out
it broadened a little bit to include
other nuisance matters such as some
containers caravans things like that and
it went out for the public and we
received submissions on it
and there was a hearing in late 2019
and then a deliberation meeting after
that
the upshot of it is that through the
deliberations
the bylaws have gone on a full circle
and come back to being a very focused
piece of work which is looking
essentially long grass and vacant
residential
sections the recommendation
here is for the council to consider that
and
recommend an adoption of that bylaw
through to the council
if the council chooses to adopt the
bylaw
there would be a public notice and then
a period if you like for it to be put in
place and then to have effect
there's one small piece of work still to
be done if that pathway is followed
and that the bylaw talks about recurring
sub-administrative charges and
inspection charges
at the moment there's nothing nothing in
the annual plan that lets us do that
so that would be if that pathway was
followed it would be brought back to the
council for an ltp
matter so in essence up until july next
year if the bylaw was
instituted now there would be a small
cost which we would have to carry
ourselves
but i don't consider that would be a
great deal
until such time as the ltp kicked in if
that was approved
thank you madam chair thank you are
there any questions
on the report uh mr mayor
thank you madam chair um mr harrison um
around the fees and charges is is that
does that have to be
resolved by an annual plan or long-term
plan process
can can that not be considered by
council outside of that
yes you did right mr mayor it can be
considered by resolutions council at any
time
um councillor redmond
uh thank you uh this is an interesting
bylaw
it seems to be addressed at long grass
and potentially fire risk
in terms of the wording it refers to
effect on immunity which is not defined
in the bylaw
is that something that should be
considered
perhaps it would be a difficult
definition to um
to focus and in the sense that immunity
is a sense of pleasantness and the sense
of pleasantness is going to properly
vary across different
different places when i consider that
the
matters that brought this to a head in
the first place was long grass
in relatively new subdivisions and it
was vacant sections which are still yet
to be built on but were unkempt
examples being pegasus or northern
rangiora
and you could say that both of those
places had a high
sense of amenity
uh supplementary to that um
the wording and nuisance control has
been deleted
is there any reason for the word
nuisance to remain in clause
three
while i turned to bylaw
okay
there's there possibly could be an
element of nuisance from some overgrown
sections
um we have an example at the moment in
northern rangiora where yes the
section's overgrown but there's also a
nuisance element attached
with irrigation hoses which are stored
on there
and periodically cast out into the
streetscape and then
cast back again onto the section by
neighbours
so you could you could deem that a
nuisance
just trying to figure out how i can ask
this as a question
the word does the word nuisance appear
anywhere else in the bible
i'm not sure i'd have to scan through it
i could help you with the answer thank
you
just a quick question from me mr
harrison
they talked about a 12-month review and
and reading through the comments as far
as
some members were quite uncomfortable
with the bylaw um the 12-month review
what would be the cost of a review to
council
it depends on how the council would
choose to review it
you could review it by considering the
matter itself on the papers
and your own sense of how well placed
the bylaw remains
or you could go to write to the extreme
end of it and do another special
consultative procedure
so in this by-law
is the council proposing that they'll
actually go and mow the grass
to actually fix the problem or is it
just
a letter that's basically it it depends
there would be a process where there's
an inspection
and a letter to the owner and a period
by which the owner has to
fix the problem and if it's not fixed at
the end of that period
then council can cause the property to
be mowed
so wouldn't that process though cost
more than actually just mowing the
property
potentially
are there other questions
moving what's in the water paper mr me
is moving what's in the order paper is
there a seconder for this
councillor second name
oh thank you look i'm not going to say
that um
from the from the questions that
everything's absolutely perfect and can
be confined this is to become
the reason for proposing this bylaw
in the first place was to deal with
situations that arise
that we just simply don't have the power
in which to deal with at the present
time
it's to be more a discouragement to
those that actually
cause this problem um then actually
you know i'm hoping that in the in the
end that would stop
uh particular behaviors but there's an
ability for council to recover costs
at the extreme it would that would need
to be tested through
the court process but that's at the
extreme one would hope that
common sense would prevail and and the
instances that the knowledge is there
there's a stick in which to
to discourage certain behaviors that are
happening and
what i've been involved in that which
drove me to this
where they were simply warring neighbors
going on quite unnecessarily
because there was no power in which to
deal with this this here
has been well supported by the parties
that
um certainly brought the attentions to
my concern
uh i've also discussed today in the in
the area of pegasus as well and they're
awaiting
uh this to come about to deal with
problem areas
i would hope that at the end of it it's
a it's a tool that we didn't have to use
but it's something in our toolbox so
initially it was to be just property
property related issues
after going out to consultations to all
the boards
it was extended and broadened but i'm
actually quite happy that its focus has
come back really mainly on
unkemp sections and long brass that
causes issues
particularly in residential areas which
is what it's confined to
around the fees and charges i think
this is a matter that should come to
council and if this does get through
this committee today perhaps it's
a separate uh paper mr harrison at a
point that the council
should consider those fees and charges
not uh
and we need to i'm quite comfortable for
that to be considered outside the ltp
process because we should be able to be
in a position to recover those costs it
shouldn't be a cost of the council
should necessarily have to be a but this
is a this is a matter that was brought
to me
um it was a response to to that
supported by council williams at the
time
i just like to thank the hearing panel
for the work that they've done
considering deliberate of the
deliberations that they've gone through
in this measure
and i just urge the committee to support
it it's a common sense way forward
hopefully acts as a deterrent rather
than something that we actually have to
enforce with a good luck council
atkinson
you know i just want to reiterate that
and i think that the committee has
no doubt been through the questions that
are raised here today
and no doubt a lot more questions that
will have been arranged
around this so i i'm actually
comfortable with a
uh with the bylaw as it is um where it
goes to from here in its future
we will see what gets tightened up
slackened off if it's of any use at all
but
uh it's it's a tool that's there that
needs to be used at the moment it's been
raised by many
and um thank you to the working party
for getting it to
here speaking to it next myself and then
councillor blackie and councillor
stewart
and i'm not going to vote for this today
i've read the minutes very very
carefully and it appeared there was
quite a lot of discussion
about how to affect any change through
this by-law
um and the fact that it's been brought
back to us with a 12-month
review shows that the the committee
seems to be a little bit
uncertain about how this by-law is
actually going to work
it's to me this is a community issue
this is neighbors next to neighbours
who are concerned mainly about amenity
if there is a fire risk
fence deals with it if there is a health
risk um
we can deal with it under our um
under the district health board this has
been watered down to be about long grass
in just on a section and the easiest way
to fix long grass on a section is just
to mow it
now we've been told that it's illegal
for council to enter
sections just to mow the grass but we've
also been told that the cost
of going through this process and going
through the bylaw going through a review
and now with fees and charges to come
into it to try and
actually bring some money back to
council for the costs incurred
um it would be cheaper just to go and
mull it
now a lot of these orlando's we're
dealing with the absentee land owners
they live overseas a lot of them and
they have had letters sent to them
they have had requests to have the grass
done through um
some avenues such as pegasus through the
pig pegasus property owners
and in other areas neighbours have
talked to them
so i don't believe letters are going to
make any difference
if we really thought that this process
was going to make a difference i'd be
voting for it
but the cost is too high it's overly
bureaucratic and if a neighbor is
worried about long grass
the easiest situation is for them to go
and mow it
and i'm not thinking that any person
who's an absentee landowner that's not
actually going to reply to any
letters that have already been sent is
going to complain about someone actually
going over and fixing the problem
we've only had seven official complaints
in the last three years
seven complaints and we're spending
thousands of dollars
on enacting and reviewing and then
resubmitting on a bylaw i believe this
is a waste of money
and under the current covet environment
we should not be wasting money
we should not be engaging in neighbour
wars and we should not be enacting a
bylaw that's going to have absolutely no
effect
councillor blackie yes i'm
madam chair you race raise some points
there we didn't debate those
um this this might appear to be simple
or simplistic it's probably a better
word
and that that and that it wasn't at all
the three of us spent a lot of time on
it
and we wound up where it is because of
the fact
of the fact is that we can't control and
and okay
we get that the by-law the bylaw system
is what it is
there were too many things where in the
to almost a too hard basket like urban
versus rural
you you can't control ground grass in a
rural situation
you just can't we talked about it for
half an hour and things like the
we removed other things um like
containers and
cording and all the things because
either another statue covers them
or something or another another rule
covers them and
we left i asked nick to leave the word
nuisance in there
just once be just just to cover our
butts because
deliberately keeping it wide because our
nuisance is what we decide can be a
nuisance
if there's no word in there it uses then
as you've said it's all about
long grass only and i didn't want that
to happen so yes
it's simplistic and and i'm quite
comfortable with the year review because
it is a trial run but i can assure you
that
having a whole lot more stuff in there
we debated that at huge length and
we couldn't make that work so we have
narrowed it down but i'm uncomfortable
with that
councilor stuart
thank you madam chair now i tend to
side with your own view about this even
though i sat around
the panel and went through as councillor
blackie
articulates um all the
various permutations of this and we have
come down
essentially to a long grass in
urban areas by law but in saying that
um can you just a question i have here
4.5
on page two
creates a habitat suitable for women to
live
and breed surely that would be
um under the health act
here so i just wonder why
because that was clearly advice that we
had
that anything that created a health
hazard
was not in here it was it was covered by
other legislation or regulation that we
had
i do think that in fact it would be
a far better community outcome
if the council had a small fund and
fronted up and just
mowed these sections as some as the
chair has said
seven complaints in three years and
presumably from that some action
that the council undertook and then
build
um the um absentee or
landowner that was unable or
through health issues uh couldn't
couldn't
do the job and really that's that's
the landowners you're dealing with
they're either absentee and there's
the chair said don't care and not there
to
to do anything about it and and then
there is
issues of uh physically unable to
keep um keep this um
this expected visual amenity of the
surrounding area
their property and there are some and
then there are some
health issues where people either well
again physically or mentally are unable
to
deal with the section now um
you can go this way um i don't actually
as i said after sitting round the back
and forth i really don't support this i
think it's
pretty much a mallet for a um
a small piece of stone
that you're thumping and it would be far
better and i think the council could
claim
kudos for actually stepping up
and um for perhaps three or four
thousand dollars
that you had in a fund that would go out
there
and mow these sections and
even talk to the neighbours and ask them
to do it
you know pay their petrol or something
but better community outcome
you may ask a question um mr harrison
how did this get here if we've got two
members of the
of the uh committee that are not in
agreement with what
what is written on this on this by-law
can you
was there not agreement that it was
coming to you or what's
yeah the committee was checked order
please suggested
the committee was chaired by council of
duty um
councillor blackie and councillor
stewart comprised the committee
uh it would be fair to say it was a two
to one
in favor of the bylaw
order i'm i'm just i'm really confused
because
council blackie said he agreed with what
the cheer was saying which was
opposing now councilman stewart
was is agreeing with sorry i don't say
now sorry but my understanding is that
councillor
was agreeing with the chair that uh i i
i can see your point but i don't think i
i don't think councillor blackie was
agreeing with me
but um i think we need to move forward
to
if anyone has any other questions or
wishes to speak
councillor redmond then councillor duty
thank you madam chair i'd like to speak
excuse me
generally i'm supportive of a bylaw to
address the mischief
and in this case the mischief does
appear to be urban long grass
and the fire risk that may go with it
but my only
issue really relates to the definition
of long grass
it's not really defined in my mind
and it does include a habitat suitable
for vermin to live and breathe well i
mean
how on earth are you ever going to
enforce uh this bible or when the
definition is pretty vague
you could sort of drive a bus through it
i think
and in lawrence it would possibly be
void for uncertainty
if a prosecution was ever commenced
because
what is amenity to you and to me it may
be different what it is to
uh councilman atkinson
i would like to see the definition
tightened up and it would be quite easy
just to say grass over
12 inches high or 24 inches come up with
it
as standard what is long grass
but just to say that you know if you're
in
the fennelton of brangyora then you
expect a lower level and if you're in
the sort of
alisa suburb of rangiora where a
different standard would be acceptable
um i think it needs an objective measure
rather than a subject
of one so that's really my only concern
i like the idea of
a short concise by law i think it's a
case that
less is better so i think the committee
or the hearing panel did well to get rid
of some of these problematic areas
i'm still not sure how we end up with
the word nuisance and the objects when
it's not referred to anywhere else
because the object doesn't create an
offence it's just really trying to set
out its purpose
so um i'm not going to say i'm sitting
on the fence but i do have that
reservation i'm sitting in the section
councillor duty thank you i would just
like to
um say that the committee the hearing
panel
really worked very hard on this there
was a lot of things in here that we
decided to delete out because they fit
it into other sections
and this is where we've got down to
simply because
the matter of of long grass
has been quite an issue in our
and our awards and it was an opportunity
then just to tidy this up
so that that obviously the word long
grass
doesn't fit the bill correctly so
it just needs to be just tidied up a bit
but
there's so many things that have
that that just don't fit into different
areas and this particular one
did not fit anywhere simply because of
the change
of our fire rating
and this is how this has come about
any just would like to say no no the
committee actually worked really hard we
had we
we really discussed this in fall and
we went all in agreeance with it at
different parts and this is what we've
come up with a very
short bylaw but
to me it is actually a really good buy
you can't have a second question
absolutely
could the spy law be referred back to
the hearing committee
to reconsider the definition of long
grass
yes good
are you moving a procedural motion in
that order
no he's oh he can't there's no one who
[Laughter]
cares um
yeah committee can't i think or at least
i'll allow it that that he will be able
to move a procedural motion
um and my understanding of standing
orders is that you can
can move a procedural motion at any time
well in that case madam chair i would
move that the bible will be referred
back to the hearing committee
to reconsider the definition of long
grass
in clause 4.5 and in the nuisance aspect
as well
well i can live with nuisance it doesn't
add anything to it um
all right it's just a word in there that
is meaningless so you're just limiting
that to the requirement of the long
i think as far as the bible goes 4.5 is
the issue
right and seconding that now this is a
procedural motion so there's no
discussion or debate on it that's simply
a vote of the committee so i'll put that
all those in favor please say aye
nobody speaks for the procedural motion
yes um and against
that's carried i'll declare that carried
it's now referred back to the
to the um hearing committee councillor
blacky can i ask a question
um could you
take us out into a workshop the
committee could make this decision in 60
seconds now if you want me honestly
i'd prefer it was done properly she came
back to the next meeting
i'm sorry but that's what we've actually
that's actually we've actually moved is
for it to go
thank you because we've actually got
another meeting following this one i'm
afraid
right um sorry moving on from that one
we still haven't seen our deputation
obviously this um that's all right so
we'll move on to 6.2
thank you for your patience with that
debate um on heritage by just
the biodiversity and ecological fund we
have
kate's coming to present to us
you just turn your microphone uncle
thank you
so what i have here is an
application to the heritage biology and
ecological fund
for some weed control in
springvale wetland which is a
12.3 hectare wetland
at 408 ashley road summerhill
so this is site
14v145
the current district plan um
and it has um
like like many wetlands it has an issue
with um body weeds so
sort of cracking ray willow cherry ash
warborn
that kind of thing and the
environment canterbury biodiversity
officer for the district has
worked with the landowner to develop a
management plan
including the provision of three quotes
so that is so the the total cost of the
project
is estimated at 21 000 gst exclusive
and that is for weed control over three
years
ecan are proposing that they fund 14
000 of this through the immediate steps
fund
and they're asking us to contribute 7000
through the contestable fund
so the landowner
has agreed to uh
contribute in kind um
by doing ongoing maintenance after the
the three years of specialist we control
work i complete
um yeah
any any questions questions counselor
atkinson
hey madam chair just um so we have the
the ho the sorry the landowner uh
talking about
after the three years what checks and
misses we have on that that's carried
out
uh so what we have is we have an
accountability agreement agreement that
will be signed between the applicant
and the council and then we can ensure
that there is ongoing monitoring done
of that of that agreement every couple
of years or so to ensure that the weed
control work is being carried out in
perpetuity
just a question question from me
kate um if this work is done over the
three years
how long an expectation if nothing else
was done would it take for the weeds to
recover from that
treatment approximately um so the poor
employee who scoped the work said that
the doing the work was effectively sort
of setting the wetland back
20 years in terms of weed invasions so
it would be a pretty significant
biodiversity gain and you would get a
a fairly long period of time before the
weeds would return to the
state that they are at the moment thank
you
uh counselor thank you kate just a query
please um just to make
clear was that person one of the 18
applicants that applied for this
their original funding no i don't
believe so
i don't know i'm just asking the
question
last year
[Applause]
i uh ken robinson um
i i
uh sorry i can't i can change that
discussion but
there was there were more than one in
that area i believe from my
understanding
i would i would appreciate police
clarification
absolutely yes thank you are there any
other questions of the report
considerate concern around the
allocation from immediate steps they've
actually got that
so they actually have a full plan
that'll
that will cover immediate steps funding
yes correct so um immediate steps have
funded that
and there is a there is a full plan
thank you
is anyone prepared to move or any
further questions
from the committee uh councillor
atkinson moves is there a second
councillor edmund councillor atkinson i
think this is
the diversity fund's sitting there been
sitting there for a while
and uh clearly bringing kate on board
has moved some things forward and we're
it's clearly where it should be and
working well so
gain the immediate steps funding
actually
gives me confidence that we should be
putting out
our heritage fund in towards helping
this happen
i'm always concerned with the and in
kind
of after three years uh actually
happening
because uh while we enter these things
in good faith and i have no doubt
of these people at all they could sell
the farm tomorrow if you like and it
could disappear into the world of
nothing so
um i'm always a little concerned around
that but the biggest thing
for uh for getting rid of these weeds is
not getting rid of the weeds it's the
maintenance that happens afterwards
and the ongoing stuff councillor edmund
thank you madam chair um i'm
pleased that ecan are contributing
two-thirds of the cost we're only being
asked to contribute one-third
from a fund we have designed for this
purpose
so the cost is minimal and it appears
the benefits will be significant
so it's not an area of woody we that i
know too much about
um i won't mention the word roundup um
so um i i think it's a very worthwhile
thing and i'm very pleased to support
the
application for funding
um i i too support this i was at the
land and water committee and it was a
good discussion there it makes perfect
sense
kate really pleased to have you
obviously you've been on board for some
time but we've been
waiting uh i guess your involvement to
take this fund and work with its
purposes to the level it needs to be we
had the number of submissions
about that over the years about making
sure that we use the
this fund for what its purpose should be
broadly more than just heritage but to
utilize biodiversity and ecological
means so i'm really pleased
to see this here and in full support so
thank you for your work on it
councillor stewart thank you manager
yes i just said my voice to supporting
it
i do seem to think that it came to the
hearing that we had
with them on the fund last year and we
identified that it would be more
appropriate for it to apply for
immediate steps for me but maybe i'm
wrong
however you know clearly a candidate
for fun um for monies both from
our own um heritage um and
biodiversity and ecological fund and
as kate has indicated i think that it's
all really being granted we
steps in london on the basis that we
actually contribute as well
so yeah certainly encourage you to
support it in the form
thank you we've now had a greater reply
counselor and consumer
all right um i don't know we'll put that
recommendation as it is in your order
paper
all those in favor please say aye
against
i'll declare that carried
6.3 thank you kate
6.3 the annual report to the
alcohol regulatory licensing authority
tracy founding
welcome tracy
right uh has the report being read
by all it's open to questions i suppose
is there anything you'd like to
highlight at the start or just straight
into questions
there's not probably a lot of highlights
um aside from the fact that we now have
councillor redmond
on board and one of the recommendations
is to get him approved as a commissioner
at a later date
are there any questions of this report
just to say firstly thank you tracy for
the report but also to
thank the committee for all the work
that's done there's a high amount of
time that goes in and particularly from
deputy mayor atkinson
he spends a lot of time working with our
staff to make sure that
we've got the appropriate regulatory and
licensing work going on so and i know
how much work goes in there so very
appreciative of that
i i see very few or here very few
complaints these days which
um speaks to the good work of our staff
out there who are clearly working
alongside in fact i get good comments um
from patrons about how they're being
dealt with and they they appreciate that
so thank you for
the work that's going in there to manage
that
in terms of the appointment of a new
commissioner
i think councillor edmund would be an
excellent addition
he brings wide skills as a retired
lawyer but
also a wide community knowledge so i
think
he will make a fine addition to the
licensing committee so
i have no hesitation in supporting the
recommendation and thanking
staff and as i mentioned the committee
for the work
councillor atkinson i just want to
thank the staff and their support that
they give the dlc um
uh everything that we do is always
supported and
um supported well and certainly nick
tracy raj
you know why the end and sharon
look after us fairly well in that space
so
i i just think that the whole dlc
uh and the way in which we interact with
the
the other authorities is extremely
important to us
to its success in the community and um
i think me is absolutely right we have
less complaints than we used to
about uh alcohol misbehavior if you like
you certainly don't get
complaints about good behavior
but we certainly have less complaints
about that and um
contrary to what you hear around the
country um
i believe that the the licensing act
is working in new zealand and um those
who aren't using that act correctly
means that they're having bad results
but in this district we're actually in
my view having good results
uh for what we're doing so um i i put it
down to just
just a whole team of people working
really collaboratively together
and and making things happen when they
need to
thank you for the speakers counselor
edmond
thank you madam chair i'd also support
the recommendations in the report
um i had my first hearing yesterday
and uh i think that went well um
so i'd just like to say that the lies
district licensing committee is a
professional little unit
and i have favorable impressions of how
it's
resourced and uh managed
um one of the things that
this council has is a lap and
one of the comments that the police have
made is that since the lap was
introduced
the 1am closing has cut down
on a lot of trouble that would occur
between 1 a.m and
after 3 a.m so i think we've got a
system that's working very well in the
district and the community is benefiting
from it
and i'd also like to um acknowledge
neville's work as chair of that
committee
um and i'm sure he puts in a lot more
work than i've actually observed
behind the scenes so i i'm very pleased
to uh support this report
and the recommendation and the report to
allah
thank you councillor duty thank you i
would also like to concur with it
to say thank you very much for the staff
for working with with us and
and training us and encouraging us to do
um training online so
it's it's a a very important
committee and to the more training that
we do the better
so say thank you and welcome
welcome
any further speakers
write a reply mr means
all right we've got the the report as it
is in your order paper the motion on the
table
all those in favor please say aye
against i declare that carried
and congratulations council redmond
all right moving on to 6.4 tracy you get
to stay in the hot seat
and so this is the dog control much more
exciting
let's go to opposite extremes
[Music]
um i'm just reading
through this if there's anything that
kind of jumps out
otherwise i'll open it to counsellors
let him cheer for any questions any
questions of the dog control report
there appear to be none uh you'll get
off very very lightly there today
um is someone happy to move the report
councillor redmond and i'll second that
myself councillor edmund
thank you madam chair this is another
area um in my portfolio
it's quite a diverse uh area from
alcohol to dogs
and other things um i do note in the
summary that there have actually been
less issues in the last
year but interestingly more
infringements
so um it looks like we're having fewer
issues but we are
actually monitoring the ones we have
much more stringently
so i'm very pleased to support the
recommendation
yes i know from the report also that
covert had some influence on that
obviously people not going out and about
with dogs
in public places perhaps as much um but
i was also similarly pleased to see the
infringements
um as we know it's it's there's no such
thing as a bad dog there's a bad owner
and it's obvious that these are being
followed up um well
and the people can have confidence that
if there is an issue that will be dealt
with
so i'm very very pleased to see this
report
any further speakers write a reply
i'll put the report all those in favor
please say aye
against declare that carried thank you
very much tracy
right moving on to 6.5 psycho
oh i can't even say that psychoactive
products retail location
lindley please take the chair
so are you reviewing what products we're
supposed to be selling now
that's what it sort of sounds like but
we go from alcohol to drugs
[Laughter]
and dogs yeah the psychoactive
substances
act of 2013
brought into being the opportunity for
council to
either have a psychoactive products
retail locations policy or not
but i'd like to go back a little bit to
2005 when the
local residents in kaiapoi were very
upset about a
shop appearing in their midst
advertising party pills
moved forward about four years to 2009
and we have herbal heaven
and katie's giftware in the hansen's
building and kaipoy
both selling these legal highs as they
became known as
mainly bzp which i think is ecstasy or
some such
at that stage um mp mr
cosgrove had a little bit of a stash
with the owner over a car park
and opportunity at that time there was a
members bill going through parliament
around
psychoactive substances which
subsequently became the psychoactive
substances
act mr cosgrove was leading the charge
on this particular act
saying that these drugs getting into our
communities was was not a good thing
um and they were very concerned the
government of the day
and indeed across the political spectrum
were very concerned about the new
generation of pills that were starting
to be developed overseas
and appearing on shelves in new zealand
without any controls whatsoever
so the ability to develop a
policy meant that our council and our
community had some sort of control
over where potentially a retail premise
could
set up shop in our district
we thought long and hard about this
consulted broadly across our community
the police the health experts
and um the crux of the
ability to do this policy uh meant that
we had to choose somewhere
that a policy that a retail outfit could
actually set up
under the act we were not able to in
effect
ban a premise from the district
now our community was very hot on that
when we did our consultation
they said we actually want you to ban it
and we want you to lobby central
government to say that these products
will be banned in new zealand
that wasn't possible well we did do that
but the upshot was that no change was
made but in effect the government
said that unless a product was actually
approved it could not be solved
to date not one single product has been
approved
at the time we had one application in
our district for
a warehouse or a wholesale outfit
to be set up into a kiwi that was the
only application i've found on the
ministry's website
for our district but as i said no not
one single
product has actually been approved in
new zealand for sale
so in reviewing this policy and
recommending no changes
i believe that what we have is
sufficient
our mapping of our sensitive sites and
the potential areas we could have
a retail outfit set up is
reasonably tight as you'll see from the
map it also gives us the ability to
review that map anytime that we
receive an application um the police
originally wanted
any premise to be right opposite their
building and behind where the garages so
they could actually keep an eye on it
from upstairs
um that didn't quite work but uh they're
very strong on the idea that
any premise that we put in should be
able to be under surveillance very
easily
so i'd be happy to answer any questions
if anyone's got any questions on this
policy and
um councillor atkinson's got the first
question leave it to you
i actually have a couple of three
actually and i'm not sure which end of
the table will answer these whether it
wasn't
but there are actually some fundamental
questions um
around the policy and whether we should
be reviewing it now and how nimble we
are with it
you just explained we can alter the map
whenever we want
given that there's a referenda in front
of new zealand
and my understanding of the
act as it's going to be presented to
parliament is
that councils will have no say
in where a well i'll call it a legal
high shop
um who will go um but i'm not sure
whether you've got an illegal tavern a
legal high tavern or what what what it
is my question is
that it would this be better
held off with no changes until such time
as that act
is either enforced or not
um so that we could or not
make the appropriate adjustments to this
policy
to cover off what would what the
referenda
is asking new zealand to do because we
do not have
like it's we don't have a dlc if you
like
because government is going to tell us
where these can go
this is actually a statutory review we
have to review our policy within the
five years and this is within our
five-year period so we
are obliged and even though we're
proposing basically to
just roll it over with no change but
you're quite right we can review it at
any
time we want to but this particular
review is a statutory review
if we don't review it um we are then in
limbo and we have no control over where
any of these premises go in our district
yep mr harrison as well just just just
to support uh
lilly but also council atkinson's um
question
is um the council could at any time by
resolution choose to review this again
so we completely understand and
acknowledge that we're going to be
working in the dark until we know
what any future legislation comes
through with regard to marijuana
um and even how that's going to be
administered
we're in the dark so perhaps a pathway
forward is to
review it now and then i just
well i wonder whether adding the
glasses can't see
oh it's a down the bottom a b c d
a
another b um whether adding something
that we
um to just just in light of and i just
want to ask this question
it would be helpful or not that um if
that act is passed
that we review this policy at that time
um it's just a reminder to do it i'm not
suggesting that
um i'm not suggesting that it's not
adequate or that we
can't do what we're doing today but just
that that's entirely
in the realm of your decision
councillor edmund thank you
i think my question has been partly
answered it was going to be
um in the unlikely event marijuana is
legalized
does this by law is marijuana a
psychoactive
substance which i suspect it may be and
if so
does it fall under the spy law and the
follow-on
from what uh councillor atkinson was
saying so your question
would the spy law control uh the
location of the sale of marijuana
i suspect not um
i would imagine there'll be a whole raft
of um
legal things around the legalization
of cannabis for sale um
there's no indication at this stage of
how the government's
is planning on doing this um
whether it'll be something like a local
alcohol policy whether we might have a
cannabis committee set up for
for monitoring it's really hard to say
um
or whether it's going to be a national
direction which i hope uh
it's impossible to say and i suspect
that these policies
i think they were put in place for the
the funny pills
the the odd things that had no controls
over them whatsoever they were
party pills they were legal highs that
um
had all sorts of really horrible
ingredients that were causing a huge
amount of harm
not to say that your cannabis couldn't
be in the same situation
but yeah it's hard to say what they'll
do with this
act and the legalizing of cannabis act
to somehow make sense of it all and have
it
hold together for the community so it's
very clear about where the lines
are drawn counselor mailings
hello there um i think it's quite timely
that we're actually looking at this now
so that we do have something
that we can hit the ground running if in
fact
um cannabis is legalized for
recreational use
and and i dare say that it is a
psychoactive thing my question
is um why is there not
um why why is the only map that i can
see on this report in rangira
that's a good point after a consultation
last time around
we discussed at length with the
community about
where potentially they thought we could
have
a retail outlet for selling um
at illegal highs the kaiapoi community
was
very strong on rejecting their
town centre as an opportunity place for
one of these
premises having been burned previously
oxford equally the young people
particularly in oxford were
adamant that they did not want one of
these shops in oxford
and rangiora drew the short straw
but also as just natural surveillance we
had
a good-sized police force here police
were very
happy to concentrate it all in one area
rather than spread it across the
district
they wanted it controlled contained and
where it could be monitored easily and
effectively
so rengar is the only place where it
could be not to say that there are no
controls on other places
yes thank you that's what i wasn't sure
about thank you
mr mia then they just are
on their counselor mailings question
which is a good question actually
what consultation have we had with our
boards
on this review of this policy
at the moment we haven't been to the
boards um it's come to you and i think
um number e is that the report and the
policy will be
circulated to the boards um
subsequent to this meeting my my
question then would be
um do you well do you
to mr harrison do you think we should be
consulting with our boards
first before agreeing to this policy
being
adopted given
that that's a difficult one and why i
say difficult because i remember back to
the first round of consultation back in
2015 and that was
extremely thorough consultation back
then and there were some very
firmly held views around the district um
so that in essence that ended the
only possible location if you like the
application of this policy was
a small area in the centre of rangiora
the only place which could fit in the
setback distances from any sensitive
site
i'm struggling to think that that has
actually changed over the last five
years
do we actually have to have a defined
location
yes we do we do we do by looking by law
we have to we can't
escape having a location that's yeah
that's a requirement of the act
okay thank you
any further questions on that
oh just one more from me keep reading
i've got that on
um and it's a slightly sideways question
um vaping in sales of vaping
what is that covered under particularly
for like high school students and so on
interestingly i thought about that as
well um vaping
the uh addictive substance in vapine is
nicotine
and you can buy various strengths of the
the other thing that goes into a vaping
cigarette or
apparatus is a flavor a food flavoring
and that's actually controlled by the
food act
and theoretically that flavoring does
not have any
other substance in it it should be
completely harmless and controlled by
the food act
so nicotine is your only product in
there that um is
of an addictive um
type thing so it they it does not come
under this particular act
and yeah although not desirable around
our sense through sites and schools
children it's not covered by this
particular act it's covered by the
sailor tobacco is that correct or not
i'm not sure why my research that i did
it didn't
wasn't clear i would imagine it would be
has its own would it be possible to give
some information on that
that's certainly been a point of
interest in our community that's of
concern
to some parents right thank you
any further questions on this particular
report and if someone prepared to move
something
uh you'll move it as in the water paper
well
bottom a becomes e yes
mr mill second councillor atkinson this
is
um oddly enough right smack bang in the
middle of the consultation that this is
the first time
which in a lot of places was was not
that
um not that pleasant in saying that
some of the people who sold these uh
substances actually turned up to the
consultation to have their say which was
really interesting um
nothing is uh has
made it through if you like
the process of becoming a legal
substance
however they still are there and sold
until they are proved they are not so
they still exist
and they're still there and um there's a
couple of places there's one and one in
hornby
one on the uh in the mall in the palms
that actually sell these substances
until such time as they are proved to be
a substance in which they can't sell and
all that happens is
these people just move to the next
substance
produce that again and until such times
that's proved to be a substance
they continue to sell it so it's
actually
we actually need this or otherwise it
can still happen within our communities
unfortunately the little nucleus of
in the middle of rangiora was the only
one without sensitive sites which was
really the telling point for us
that um that could be there we probably
should have done this in committing and
then no one would have known that site
by now even exists
so i'd say their tummy tongue and cheek
but
another way of control i space my
questioning around the cannabis laws are
that
um it is psychoactive
by its definition and if you read what
the government has on its site
um in the referenda and the bits that
have been introduced to parliament so
far
it is absolutely correct that the
government uh
indicating that they will control it and
that they
will tell people where it's going and
that concerns me greatly
especially in light of the report that
the dlc has just put
to this committee it concerns me greatly
that a government can come in
in the government and we've had this
with three waters we've said it many
times the government told us through the
earthquake
we don't know our community your
community you need to deal with them
in your recovery plans because you know
them best however
when it comes to these things they put
them over the top of us
and almost remove us from the exercise
now that exercise isn't here yet
but if you read the paperwork that's
there and it does come
they can actually decide for us if
someone wishes to take a shot
where it's going to go now
of course it has to pass first for that
to happen i was trying to think of if we
could be
prepared and whether this will cover
that
or not and we won't know until that's
passed i mean that that's absolutely
true
but i would suggest that it's probably a
really good starting point for us to
if we have to fight back because i'm not
saying you wouldn't book
a um a cannabis tavern in the middle of
town i mean
well that's what they are i mean never
look overseas or what they are that's
what they are
so i'm not saying we wouldn't do that
because it would be something that's
legal and it's pretty hard to
stop something that's legal going
somewhere
but under this we may be able to do
something if it was
the pressure from the community was
something that we
felt we needed to deal with so that's um
that's the reason for my questioning
around there and i just want the
committee to be aware and certainly our
regulatory department that i will be
keeping my eye on that legislation and
where it goes and what it does
so that in between dlc's psychoactive
substances all of those
that we actually do have a say as a
community as to what can happen
in the future
thank you to support the uh
recommendation and thank lilly for the
work on this i hadn't appreciated the
area in rangira was confined and we
actually had to have one in a
set area um within the district and i
guess
um thank the rangyor community for
taking one for the team
i really do hope that it doesn't come to
us having
one of those doors here i don't
personally like them i don't like the
cause it's so the harm
the potentially causes to young people
on taking such substances or
it becomes an entree onto other things
but i appreciate there's a national
legislative national legislation
governing it
my understanding with the referendum um
is that it's non-binding the referendum
that the government's
got out so that they'll be out on um uh
cannabis reform or legalization of
cannabis so
it'll be interesting to see if it is
agreed whether
or not a potential government will and
what they will do with that referendum
and that's a guide on the couple of
public sentiment and that
seems to be from some polls you see
quite evenly balanced in terms of its
opinion but
we will see where people um vote on that
and i'm not going to express a
particular view on mine
on that but it's just i think councilor
atkinson is absolutely right
we need to be contemplating that um
if it does happen and then what our
response would be here at the local
level and that's something we would need
to deal with
appropriately at that time vaping i
think that was a very good question
from councillor barnett because i've
certainly had a lot of questions about
it
particularly having been involved
in some of the discussions with a
retailer and then not a retailer a um
landlord and the potential of it coming
into the main street in mangura
there is a store a dairy that sells it
now
it was looking to be a bit more front
and center
and right on the center there which you
know rightly so a number of retailers
were particularly concerned about its
effect
so um i don't personally have a problem
with people that vape that's their
choice
just would rather the stores not front
and center and
their prime area and our main streets
which was the concern that was expressed
to me
so uh look um support the policy um good
work lilly
um and uh as as right as we've indicated
that we'll keep an eye on the other
changes which may come about through
parliamentary processes thank you
just speaking it to myself i support
exactly what the other speakers have
said
and i think we could be distracted by
the cannabis
referendum it's going to be a very long
process there
have to be an act put together would
have to be debated it would have depend
on the mnp status of the government
so we've got a huge long process but
definitely good to keep it in mind
however it's not relevant to
what we can do under this policy so
therefore it's
um we've got to get this one done so
we've got to get that
completed um i take um the mayor's point
that
it's often i do prefer things going to
community board first because we get a
feeling of the sentiment
however this policy there's absolutely
no change from when it was done
five six years ago and so and we we've
gone down to the absolute
minimal that we possibly can under the
law
so i i believe that perhaps the
community board would feel quite
frustrated that they can't actually
change that
and it would be unlikely to result in a
major change so
i am comfortable at this point that it's
just circulated to them and
the point that council atkinson made
though about um substances are suddenly
coming out they're not approved
i i think that's a major failure of
central government and that should be
reported through to them
um it's something they are not policing
obviously well enough to keep our
communities safe and
um i think this law this should have
actually
been given some sort of local teeth so
that we could actually help with that
process
through our community services now links
with social services
and however that isn't in our realm
and we are not mandated to do it so this
is all we can do and it's the best
best of a bad bunch and so thank you
very much lynley for all the work that
you've done on this policy
any further speakers wrote for reply
you look just at last point madam chair
that um
about the um stuff being tested if you
like or being legal until it's tested
otherwise it's uh the ministry of health
did take that on
and they did fight that in court and so
did the government try to pass
legislation but it was proved that you
actually
cannot do that you cannot
um it's like proven guilty until such
time as they've proven innocent
they must prove that it is a
psychosubstance in the first place and
they must prove that it is
that it can cause harm before they
illegally write it off
thank you thank you thank you for that
um i'll put the motion as it is in your
order paper all those in favor please
say aye
against i'll declare that carrie thank
you very much lily
right quick stretch we're on to 6.6
we're doing well guys
um there's 6.6 matches speaking on this
one on the submission to
private plane change rcp 29 the somerset
villages
thank you man thanks alan firstly
apologies from sam who is really looking
forward to presenting this today but
she's unfortunately sick so
i've stepped in for her um just in terms
of
referring to the reporter i wouldn't
mind just if i could take you through
um some comments on paragraph 3.7
in respect of the mps for urban
development
which has advanced quite rapidly on from
the time that we wrote this report
and that we first talked to you about uh
potential council submission
so essentially the mps comes into effect
on the 20th of august then
the key effect for the submission that
we're looking to
confirm today is the requirement that
district plans can't have any
minimum car parking provisions so what
what a district plan
can do is have provisions around
car parking dimensions and and location
if if a developer does decide to
to have car parking as part of their
activity
so what that essentially means is as a
result of that
mps coming into effect um the timing of
the
of the plan change hearing for this
proposal is going to be such that we're
going to need to give some weight to
that
parking provision uh on the nps
and on a completely without prejudice
basis
it's likely that the officers are going
to give that a fair amount of waiting
given that it's a national direction
that drops down
through uh to to our district plan uh
and that that is um going to be
something for all of our resource
consents that we have going from the
from the 20th of august but particularly
uh in respect of this plan change
hearing
so that being the case the the committee
may take the opportunity to remove that
that part of the submission the
practical effect of that is that staff
will essentially make that amendment to
the
submission and then uh confirm that it
is lodged if
indeed the committee also decided to
confirm this
decision today um
so the practical effect is that car
parking is still able to be assessed
in in the general sense around some of
the matters for control
of the retirement village that are
proposed
both in them in their controlled
activity status and in the restricted
discretionary activity status which is
which is another matter for the council
submission
and there's also two other submissions
that mention car parking from members of
the public which need to be dealt with
as well uh and and thirdly
we we have talked in in the round with
the applicant around this and and
they've reiterated the
point that while they may not be
required to
have car parking it's certainly their
intention to provide
uh sufficient car parking for the
village because that's essentially the
model at which they
they work on happy to answer any
questions on
that or anything else in the report um
from there questions from counselor
edmund
ah thank you the nps
am i correct in thinking that gave
councils a period of time
within which to change their district
plan
and then considering this application
is it a matter of weight or does the nps
completely override our district plan
uh it's a really really good question
and i'm just
stretching my brain to think the the mps
essentially
um gives gives a direction and it does
give some time
for councils to amend their plan but it
doesn't specify what that what that time
period is um so there becomes a two-fold
uh point there is what at what time does
count do councils amend their district
plans
and then secondly whether or not those
plans are amended what weights
that um a council officer would give to
the
to the provisions in the in the plan uh
or the or the national direction itself
so uh and then and then separately on
on this question um there's an added
layer on top of that which is
the council's potentially adding to a
role in the in the district plan by
creating a car parking ratio specific
route
for retirement villages so um
as i mentioned the the practical effect
of that is whether or not the district
plan
does change immediately or there's a
lead in time to do that
there's still a requisite level of
waiting that will need to be given to
the national direction
for for the activity
um it probably doesn't apply to this
particular case because it's
in rengera but with the np sud i was
recently sitting on a one of the waka
kotahi
webinars on this and their expert
indicated that
on the nps indicated that the removal of
parking provision only applied to urban
centers of 10 000
populations of 10 000 people or more
do you know anything about that or have
you seen anything that would indicate
that that is the case thus far
and um so if if the downstream
um result of of this floodgates wise
um is that we have to remove them or um
yeah sorry
i'll let you speak on that no that's
great and it's a good opportunity for me
to probably address the the slightly
wider question about what happens to
removal of car parking
um my understanding just from a
um an internal meeting that we we had on
this was that yeah
that's right the mps applies to urban
centers with a population of of
of over 10 000 and there is some um
interpretation around how that's looked
at because
your smaller townships within the
districts are your custom
and those sort of things collectively
could be added up to
uh to require one of those be one of
those
capacity things it certainly does apply
to
larger settlements so kaiboy would end
and ring error
and they are certainly the areas at
which we may see the biggest impact of
the
changes to the car parking provisions uh
so they
so they do apply um
perhaps if i could extend the questions
slightly and and talk generally about
what that might mean
for four activities within within the
district plan
um we we've had a a cast around and sort
of looked at what
what impacts there would be in terms of
developments certainly for the rengar
and in in kaipoy town centre uh there
are some provisions within the plan that
would already allow us to look at things
uh ancillary to car parking that relate
to that so there's
this on-site works urban design outcomes
loading space and that sort of thing so
there's there's still a
level of of control within the district
plan
um potentially applies to residential
type
type developments now it's it's unlikely
that
the in the life of the current district
plan that we'll see a great sea change
to have people not
looking to provide garaging and on their
site so there's unlikely to be a great
level of impact
uh there so in in the round there while
the provisions come out
we're not likely to see developers only
deciding that they don't want to provide
any car parking but that's certainly
something that
the new district plan needs to work
through
further questions on the report somebody
prepared to move something
happy to move is in the order paper
seconded councillor edmund
mr man just briefly i support the
submission
and appreciate that the
submission was put in that reflected the
points that were made particularly
around
car parking i realised that that may
well change but
it's actually a regular complaint that i
have
around our current ryman
and other retirement villages and i'm
just picking on ryman not
particularly but it's just that i've
been to a number of residence meetings
down there and they complain about it
all the time
and we were pushed as a council planning
wise
to to the constraints that we could
operate under i personally wish we
hadn't
exceeded in some ways to to that because
it's created problems
down there there's not enough car parks
on site for the residents
who are there and it's become a problem
that may well be overtaken by national
legislation that hasn't at this point
so personally i think we should press on
with the matter as it is and make sure
that that's properly considered if
it changes the changes but i'm holding
true to the people who raised it to me
as an issue
and that's why i will support the
submission as it stands
thank you councillor edmond
ah thank you madam chair we're just
retrospectively ratifying the submission
that staff have lodged and i'm quite
happy
the changes
or submission that's been made i think
is quite sensible
i do have concerns about parking that
i'm sure we all share
but we'll just have to see what happens
in that space
thank you i'm happy to support this the
way it stands in the recommendations
because without parking provision
in a facility something such as this
we run the risk of you know if there
isn't parking for staff
we run the risk of only being able to
get
staff from the places that are served by
public transport
outside of our district and down the
line instead of the people here in the
waimakariri district who will have to
drive their cars possibly
to get to their place of employment and
i would really like to see
why macarooni be more self-sustaining in
its own
employment and i would like to see that
not be such a huge impact also on the
surrounding areas
so i'd like to see it as as is in the
submission thank you
just speaking to it myself um i believe
that actually leaving it in there at
this moment in time is not going to make
much difference one way or the other and
it reflects very much the view of the
council as discussed previously when
formulating the submission
and i think we've got a responsibility
to our community to state it
and it may just bring it further top of
mind for the commissioner who's actually
doing the consent so a consideration may
be done
to mitigating some of the effect whether
we are taken over by government
legislation
remains to be seen we're seeing
government take away a lot of local
control
and i i can see that this is going to
cause problems for our urban planning
going forward but that is something we
don't have a lot of control over so we
have to manage the effects of that going
forward as well
so i wholeheartedly agree with leaving
it in and
thank matt and his team for preparing
the submission
right of reply mr mayor i'll put it
all those in favor of the recommendation
say
aye against i declare that carried
thank you to sam as well
item seven referred from the community
board's
request for parking restrictions on
durham street
um joanne's not here will you speak to
that uh mr harrison yes yes i can
i can very quickly madam chairs we've
gone from a high-level policy
argument on parking right down to the
nitty-gritty of where a parking spot
goes
um the report's relatively self-evident
the medical center has asked
for previously unrestricted car parks in
the northern end of durham street to
have a series or set there where they'll
p 120 so it
provides a better facility for their
customers
it goes to the board for their
recommendation
it has yes and then um the decision is
actually
in the domain of this committee
and the board said to support it yes
thank you
councillor atkinson just wonder has
also like i'll call them parking wardens
i can't remember their real name have
they also
um had him put into this yes they have
right if there are no other questions
i'm happy to move the report as there's
someone prepared to second
councillor atkinson and in moving the
report this was supported at the
renewashi community board and i'm happy
to take their lead
plus the the traffic work that's been
done and as mrs harrison said that it's
also been consulted with our
i think it's traffic enforcement officer
and
so i'm very very i'm happy to support
this i did note at the board meeting
however that i would like to see that
more comprehensive
look at the town centers which is coming
through the strategy group
to look at parking overall in the in the
town centres
and where there should be p120s or other
types of restrictions
as we grow as as towns in as a district
secondary councillor atkinson
nothing to reply to i'll put it all
those in favor please say aye
against i declare that carried
7.1 um number eight is a memo from
bev shepard wright we're just receiving
that mr
harrison yes
thank you mr mr shepherd wright wrote a
letter to the committee
just expressing her concern about late
night noise
from essentially contractors working in
the road reserve
so we had contractors marking the road
contractors picking up rubbish and also
contractors who are putting up street
decorations
and i've attached a memo for the
committee's information just with
the how that those matters are currently
addressed at the moment
um so there over time there's been a
change from having a general policy
about ours
and those hours if you like you've been
brought into the individual contracts
which manage those particular pieces of
work
are there any i'll allow any just any
comments that uni members would like to
make about the response to
the resident at this point cancer
atkinson
well i suppose it's like uh
when you want rain you know when you
want to do your washing
i mean i certainly remember and it
wasn't emergency time so
that we had requested around our table
many times for things to happen at night
to uh for the greater good and um
and for me their road marking is
definitely one of them
i don't know if we've all driven through
christchurch and seen the white lines
which have gone away and seemed to be
halfway across the lanes and all up and
down the street
purely because they've been done during
the day and people have driven over them
so
it's done so really in in
short periods of time that i'm afraid i
believe
that our original policy is personally i
believe it is absolutely adequate
for and and stuff if it's going to be
prolonged time will bring it back to us
to make a decision on whether that's
something i mean i absolutely trust them
in that so
personally i believe that what we have i
sympathize with what mrs wright is
saying but i'm afraid
that for the greater good i believe that
the policy is correct
as it stands thank you any further
comments
don't follow up from that mr harrison
and myself will devise a letter to go
back to the resident
thank you for your feedback uh portfolio
updates
uh i'm first on the list district
planning and just want to remind
everyone that our
briefing next week has been moved from
tuesday due to another meeting
to the 28th of august 11 30 to
2 30 and there will be some important
things in that briefing so
i really encourage you all to attend um
we are
still working on work on the draft
natural hazards provision
there'll be a briefing in september
which is following up from the maps that
were accepted at council
on the fourth of august in september
also they're having a
his politic hazards policy response
stakeholders meeting including some of
the committee
and the board chairs and there's also a
meeting on the protected vegetation list
the workshop with stakeholders
and uh and staff happening in september
as well
anything from you nikki on district plan
excellent um regulation civil defence
councillor edmund
uh thank you uh just covering the four
areas
um yourself and
i meet with brennan wieremo and nick
to discuss a briefing session um for
this committee
about the strategic view of civil
defence
in the district building towards the
long-term plan
um brennan has some ideas and i think we
are actually
going very well in the civil defense
space
how do we grow the community's
resilience how do we engage with
volunteer groups
that spontaneously emerge how do we
build on other
current community networks so to try and
get that kicked off we're hoping
something might happen in september and
october
sort of a two-part process and
brennan has invited sarah stuart black
who is the director of nema
who you may have seen on tv during the
covert 19
broadcasts from time to time um
just by the way her nickname is norm
long story how she
became known as norm and she's indicated
her willingness
to come down and talk to us and tell us
about
national directions for the civil
defense emergency management
set up so brennan's working on trying to
coordinate a date and the second
difficulty is getting it in our agenda
so i've offered support
to brennan with governance to see if we
can get it in
brennan is also uh keen to talk about
the tsunami threat that modelling that
we've discussed in the past
is due out in the next couple of months
he thinks this will extend the zone
where people will need to leave
and the question will arise how do we
warn those people
at the moment we have tsunami sirens
um they're quite expensive so hence
if we were looking at putting those and
i'm not saying that that's where we're
headed
there are other technologies uh looking
at how you
um notify residents
but if sirens are quite expensive so
you'd be looking at 500 odd thousand
just as a ballpark
if we went down that path so that's
clearly
something that the ltp might need to
consider
environmental services um
there was a dlc hearing yesterday the
ivory bar was seeking a special license
to remain open for 3 am for a 30th
birthday
the inspector their tower inspector
raj medical officer of health and the
police were in opposition
i'm not sure whether i'm in a position
to say what the decision was i can
uh the committee granted the application
um and the parties have just been
notified and
the decision will be released later in
the week
it's a bit of a one-off i can say that i
think the hearing committee was
impressed with the
applicant's suitability and how they've
been conducting their business
uh dog registration a reminder has been
posted out
and if you haven't registered your dog
you will be receiving
a reminder letter there are about 900
owners
owning 1295 dogs who have been reminded
and you will have until the end of the
month to pay before a penalty applies
after the end of that month animal
control will start checking with owners
who have outstanding fees
and if you or they don't register their
dog
you get a 300 infringement notice
so all good for revenue
the dog's ability to pay yes
right uh planning uh
further submissions closed last friday
for somerset and we heard from matt
um no further submissions were received
uh 12 submissions including the council
have been received the next stage is for
the plan is to prepare a report on the
submissions
in preparation for a hearing and that
will be heard by a commissioner of
course
secondly the tag its application to
worry
the race course is still at the stage of
providing further information so it can
be assessed
tag it seemed well aware apparently of
community views
so we'll see what happens in that space
um the commissioner for kaiapoi's line
living proposal
that's the uh large village
um proposed in silverstream
um has the commission has received all
the papers
from the applicant and the council and
will now determine if a hearing will be
convened or not
and finally in the planning space the
decision on the airfield plan change is
expected shortly
uh building in july new house consents
were 54.
this compares to last year uh
with 62 so just down slightly
that number has been inflated by sergio
ravenswood
builds so far for august we've received
17 new house consent
which is certainly fewer than the 73 in
august last year
so it may be this coded uh
recession depression may just be
starting to come through
a wee bit later than perhaps might have
been first thought
so it'd be interesting to follow those
uh trends
the selwyn district council has asked
for help processing and inspecting their
building consents
and a council processor and inspector
will be seconded to sell one
on a month-by-month basis so whilst we
may have a drop off
this month um it looks as so it's
gangbusters and
rolliston and salmon district
thank you thank you councillor ebbin
such a full report
and council awards away i have no
questions no urgent general business
so i will declare this meeting closed
thank you very much for your attendance